in the Suicide Squad you tattooed your
cast members is this right yes because
you're kind of you're trained and
qualified but I said these are the
tattoos yeah we call them Tomo geez okay
and use of all the cast no weirdly
enough no one else one of them just the
two of us got the term very teased but
everyone else got squad written on them
and other people just would come by the
trailer and get anything and yeah so did
all sorts of things and he's you sort of
zoo people yeah I reckon I've done yeah
probably like getting close to a hundred
now but you know ones little ones and
honestly I'm probably getting worse as I
go along because we have a tattoo gun
here though if anyone can view of my
judgement if any of your cards want
attacked what do you to commemorate it's
lovely
[Applause]
you pierced your ear yeah not myself
[Music]
funny
let's be thinking it might but I've seen
you actually are prepared oh yeah yeah
no no she can touch this is actually my
gun but I could I can do it because
you've already tattooed yourself haven't
you
yeah how did that go for you
not great it was a you know it was
supposed to be a you know like the class
I'd like I'm a monster hand dropping a
bloody heart but it looks more like a
like a chicken you know making love of a
cactus or something Brenda's house I
like to do it all it's a bad combination
do you have a tattoos oh no do you do
yeah where is it I went to college in
the 90s no he's a dolphin no no no no is
it
the thing is the thing is there is
someone who works on our team and they
are a big margot robbie fan and they I
would I say they're willing to do this I
mean they're very keen he's washed his
feet touched them so what is it but I
mean is it difficult to do this - mogi
thing no are we fine yeah so Adam your
moment is here this is happening
[Applause]
I don't need to criticize my own
production team but you could have taken
your shoes and socks off first
it saves a little time you knew this
moment was coming I want to be more real
ok ok here we go here we go
you don't have to do this if you don't
want to I'm saying that he wants to do
things oh okay you sure yeah okay I know
there's something I have to say that
this is legally don't try this at home
okay perfect okay here we go
okay in your own time okay here we go
here we go save and um one for a while
I'm sorry I'm probably more nervous than
you oh sorry that's not comforting I'm
not going to say that was very
professional I'm so scared my hands are
shaking but you don't hear that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
does it hurt a little funny yeah don't
we make your finest work
you do seem happy in your work good I
like doing it
[Applause]
pokerface had a very good good yeah I'm
eating it up like one we're off like
backstage
[Applause]
you
[Music]